I couldn't decide whether I wanted something sweet
or savoury for breakfast, and neither could my kids,
so I decided to make a few different things.
I started off by making some homemade pistachio cranberry granola.
I mixed all of my ingredients together,
popped in the oven, and while it was cooling,
I sprinkled over some cranberries.
There's something so special about a fresh pressed orange juice,
so I obviously had to do that as well.
And then for my savory options,
I decided to do a hash with some bacon.
I peeled and grated my potatoes before squeezing out all the liquid,
and I seasoned them and gave that really good mix
and fried them in the bacon fat that was left over
after frying my bacon off.
While my hash Browns were in the skillet getting crispy,
I started making some waffles as my sweet component.
I mixed all of my dry ingredients
and then moved on to cracking some eggs,
combining that with butter, vanilla,
some milk, and pouring that into my dry ingredients.
After that was all mixed up,
I made my waffles and then moved on to a big fruit plate.
When fruit is in season, it's so,
so good to me, so I make sure to always buy things that are in season.
I cut up some plums and some white peaches for plating them
alongside some cherries, strawberries,
blueberries, and then setting that aside
while I started working on my vegetable plate,
which Was some heirloom tomatoes,
Persian cucumbers, red onions,
some salmon and parsley. Lucky requested some scrambled eggs,
so these were just for him.
I made a chive and Parmesan scrambled egg.
I don't know whether you call this a scrambled egg or not,
but this is how I make him his eggs.
I topped that with some more parmesan cheese,
and then it was time to plate everything up.
Everyone loved having these different options today,
and it was absolutely divine.